hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and tonight I
went and saw how much longer oh man I
thought I was almost done with this
video no there's 10 minutes left wow so
much to talk about you know it's just
you know you know there is definitely
gonna be spoilers in this it was just an
OK film I had fun with it and so if you
think you might want to go see and have
fun with it maybe don't watch this but
I'm not gonna not reveal every single
detail of this movie right now so just
get rap for that Hellfest is a scary
slasher movie that takes place in a
haunted house festival setting I love
the idea of it it's very relatable in
the sense that you know I've been to a
lot of haunted houses they really do a
good job playing up the aspect of like
the nervous the nervous the nervous
energy that you get at a haunted house
there's like a lot of like giggling and
like trying to act like really cool and
mostly nervousness is what I got from
the actors in it it totally made sense
it was super relatable in that sense it
also wasn't scary it was definitely
relatedly
jump scary because it's like haunted
houses you're like it's just all people
just jumping out as you go just like
that
but it wasn't scary until the very end
there was a very I would say a
suspenseful scene that was really well
done and I super enjoyed the last scene
was it was really cool oh the second to
last scene was really cool the very last
scene was a huge bummer of a reveal but
it was definitely good enough to like
get through the film with I had a good
time watching this movie it wasn't like
boring it wasn't you know a chore to get
there but it wasn't a revelation of
horror like hereditary
we just all saw hereditary was amazing
this was no hereditary my theater was
surprisingly full few people other than
myself are very ready for October to be
here and Halloween to be here I had two
other movie reviewers in my theater I
didn't ask them but they were both
writing things down in notepad so they
were either movie reviewers or like a
very big horror nerds and the rest of
the theater were a horror nerds it
seemed and it was a fun audience to see
it with though I think we were all in
the same page with it just being pretty
subpar other than that last thing I
think that really did a great job
building suspense and being scary
everything else was it was just jump
scared but it really fit in I said in
the remake of Jumanji if there were any
cheesy like CGI things or something
didn't look real it's a really easy
thing that they could play off that it's
like well we're in a video game so
that's fine it makes sense this is a
very similar thing where like we're at a
haunted house and like all of the scares
are stupid jump scares so you feel like
you're in like a really cool haunted
house for the whole movie and I really
love haunted houses and you get a
different kind of horror because you're
subjecting yourself to it and it's the
same in this like in a lot of horror
films they're not asking for these
things to happen but in this they're
asking for it Cerreta they're not asking
to be murdered brutally obviously but
they're asking for that fear and that's
like nervousness and you know high
stakes anxiety that you get at a horror
haunted house festival so it was a
relatable fear with that it was just
just kind of jump scary again other than
that last scene the film opens on a
murder that happened a few years back at
the same horror festival in another town
you see this horrific murder happen and
this guy comes into the festival he
kills this girl he uses her as a prop
and then she's there for three days
until somebody actually figures out that
she's not just a prop in the horror fest
she's a real human that has been
murdered cut to a group of six friends
three couples
who are going to this murder festival
you really don't get invested in four of
the six characters I would say I think
the two best friends are good enough
they're in the scene that I keep talking
about that was actually suspenseful at
the end and they're definitely our two
leads but the other four didn't capture
attention at all I really didn't care
about them and especially the other girl
in in this six um she was like very
aggressive she was so she's that person
that you go to a haunted house with and
it's like too excited about it that's
how they're getting their nerves out is
there like this is so much fun and
that's like literally how I am in a
haunted house and the whole time it's
just like oh my god calm down I'm like
oh wow that is me though but she was
like way too excited she also this is
such a personal thing has nothing to do
with like a reflection of the movie but
she was super gay and then like was in a
straight relationship and it was really
weird
I just wish they would have just made
her day I think it's a really good use
of haunted house lore though and they
set it up where you know you can go to
like a kibbeh one and then you go to the
next level one and then a really scary
one and then the last one they can touch
you then the very last one is supposed
to be like the end of the night like you
finish off there you've gotten that far
then you have conquered this health fest
and I like the levels that it sets up
but that's something that I would so
fall for I've been to like Six Flags
Fright Fest where it's just a bunch of
college students who are trying to make
extra money who probably are in the
theater department our pretty misery
well it's not scary and it's just kind
of fun to be there with people dressed
up trying to scare you but it's not a
scary thing and that's kind of what you
go into haunted houses with because I've
like you know seen a bunch of audition
postings for haunted houses so you go
into those things I mean like it's just
people it's just people it's just people
that's how you like keep you cool
throughout the whole thing but this guy
goes in he's an actual murderer he's
following around there's a group of
people who were knowing through this
and that's really creepy the mask is
really creepy and it's a great premise I
just wish there was more suspense and
less jump scares and I don't hate jump
scares I know a lot of people are like I
like horror but I just don't like jump
scares I like it all I love all horror I
do not mind jump scares if there's more
to it than just that but this was pretty
much just jump scares until you get to
this last scene four of the six have
been killed so we've got our two leads
that I liked more than the other and
they're going through the very top tier
and how they get there is super dumb the
park announces that they finally realize
that there's a killer amongst them
they're like evacuate and the two girls
are like well this looks like an exit
and it's literally the entrance to a new
haunted house it's clearly the entrance
to a new haunted house this is like not
like tricky like it's definitely like
this is the hell house come on in for
hell and it's like oh maybe it's Nexus
no no no no no not an exit and so that's
really dumb I hated that part but the
second they get in there they used two
really cool ways to evade the guy and
then she beats the crap out of him with
a bat and then they call the cops and
the cops come in and and it was
suspenseful it was cool it was
definitely the most scary part I
wouldn't call it scary but it was
definitely the most dispensable part of
the film in my opinion oh another thing
there's just a lot of stupid horror
tropes at one point the killer follows
her into the bathroom and like in Top
Gun same thing same basic premise is top
gun officer in and he's in the cell next
to her and she texts the guy that she
has a crush on and the killer has at
this point killed him and gotten his
phone and it's just chilling next to her
in the bathroom stall and when she texts
the guy it dings next to her and she's
like well that's weird but not weird
enough for me not freaked out so we're
just gonna keep going even though she's
been followed all night by a weirdo then
she notices that the killer is there and
she's like I'm calling the cops and then
immediately calls the cops and it's like
call has failed and Satan well you
literally you just messaged your crush
and it went through with ease and you're
in like a populated area
that there's no way that your call would
fail this is 2018 the land of technology
and the end is the killer gets away and
she like drives up to his suburban home
and he hangs his mask he locks it up
away and he walks in to a living room
and there's like a little child's on the
couch and there's like really
suspenseful music playing and then the
child wakes up I was like daddy you're
home and then he hugs her and that's the
end so this the the the like twist of it
all or like the review is that he's just
a normal guys everyday white dude it's
like I don't know it's not too hard to
believe right I don't know what I was
expecting from the reveal I was kind of
expecting there not to be a reveal that
it was just kind of like a dude but it
felt a little like just kind of forced a
bit anything was definitely the most sad
bummer II part about this film because
the rest I had a good time with I
wouldn't write this one off I think it
was fun enough see with friends and
maybe have a beer or two or three or
four or five or six or seven or eight or
nine first and enjoy it thanks for
watching I'll see you guys next week
you
[Music]